قال رئيس تركيا اردوغان ان بلاده ستشجع
عوده اللاجئين السوريين الى وطنهم بشكل
طوعي وامن بما يليق بتاريخ وثقافه تركيا
حسب تعبير
ائنا الذين لجاوا الينا فارين من الحرب
ومن هجمات المنظمات الارهابيه للعوده الى
وطنهم بشكل امن وطوعي وبالحفاظ على
كرامتهم وسنحل هذه المساله بشكل سهل يليق
بتاريخنا وبقيم عقيدتنا وثقافتنا وسنستمر
بخطنا في السياسه الخارجيه الفعاله التي
تعتمد على المبادره والقيم الانسانيه لهدف
ضمان مساهمتنا في احلال السلام على
المستوى العالمي
سنعيد طرح مشروع تعديل الدستور مره اخرى
على البرلمان وسنستمر بخطواتنا في مجال
الطاقه من غاز البحر الاسود الى النفط في
جبل جبار ومحطه اكويو النوويه وسنزيد من
اصلاحاتنا لضمان تقديم الخدمات القضائيه
بشكل سريع وفعال وسنستمر بكل حزم في
كفاحنا ضد التنظيمات الارهابيه وتجار
المخدرات وجميع الاصابات الاجراميه وسنقضي
على جميع الارهابيين